hi I'm Brent I'm Jason today we're
drawing comic strip characters from
memory I mean I know some comic strips
definitely easier than comic book yeah
if you say comic book I'd be having a
heart attack right now you're on my turf
now too bad right
he's pretty iconic yeah oh come on I
don't
I only I only know that guy from memes
watch a spare okay he's got a big nose
see the massive nose isn't 90% of his
body knows he's chill - oh he's he's
usually got like an eye closed right
yeah I think he's I think I'm seeing
that soon Oh what is this I look like
that's the thing all Peanuts characters
are made up of like three lines yeah so
if you don't get those lines down
there's no hope for you thank you it's
like Riverdale right yeah not that I
watch that show I don't watch that show
no I don't watch that I grew up drawing
Garfield's this is almost muscle memory
for me if I see it and it looks nothing
like our field you're gonna be peeved
you're gonna be peeved I mean I remember
like you know he's like this high school
dude who hangs out Jughead
he's usually has like a sweater on and
that's what I'm worried about is the
clothes lazy - yeah I think like a
sweater and like jeans and usually his
sweater has like our on it for Riverdale
okay so what does Garfield look like
Garfield's a cat his construction is big
head kind of a beam body like a beer
belly he's got like a gut your belly I
feel like some of these things are
contradictory to each other
no all right he's just gonna be sleeping
on top of his little doghouse he's got
big feet big feet like like not not like
cat feet wait so he was like it was like
human feet no okay they're like think of
clown shoes like if clown shoes had toes
I don't like that this description makes
me uncomfortable is Riverdale like a
supernatural sort of show I've never
seen it I do I just know is loosely
based off the comic how can
one can't be so difficult to draw what
am i drawing what is this oh I don't
understand not so easy to be a
cartoonist now is it Jackie what a mess
what a mess this is so I take it you
didn't read Garfield as a kid no read
Garfield who's reading some reason I
remember what he looks like when he
dances like he has his head all the way
up and you don't see his eyes he just
sees like little happy face uh-huh
I'm gonna draw him dancing - there's
poses that I sort of draw a lot so I'll
just be like you know what don't know
how to draw this guy but I do know how
to draw this pose I'm gonna draw him
sitting with his leg over his other leg
and hope that the drawing comes out okay
I'm just drawing I'm standing there wait
to Snoopy have like flat kind of feet oh
god I feel like he's got like people
feed I drew him with people feet yeah I
don't know what I'm doing he just
doesn't look like this looks like an
alien he does kind of look like an alien
like he's I feel like the character has
been around so long and he's been
refined so much that he no longer really
looks like a cat you just looks like
Garfield what dog it is a newbie I don't
know oh okay herb eels they have like
sad eyes right am I thinking of like a
my brain refuses to make this into a
thing but you've seen Garfield before I
have but I've never looked at him I just
oh wait you know what I think his ears
are together that feels like it's
correct yes ears are together I'm some
kind of genius because I'm drawing this
hand I'm realizing that I really don't
ins are definitely one of the hardest
things to draw okay I don't know what
his attitude is he's sassy and my
drawing yeah he is very sexy what are
you doing for your drawings like like
stylistically okay it's kind of a mix of
what I remember from the comic style and
just general cartoon meanness what
characters did you grow up drawing
Sailor Moon oh yeah but you know what we
don't have to color anything his guess
what he's black and white black and
white because he half of
pink tongue though I mean if you were
gonna include that tongue then I guess
yeah I think he has a song his house is
red and that's all I need to draw I kind
of want to make the lines smoother it
kind of felt like when he was drawing
them he drew them what's like a smooth
line like I did them very yeah they were
very gestural yeah like lines what I
liked about Archie from what I can
remember of him is he's really happy
looking everyone in that comic just
looks so happy what era does it take
place in obviously you have your time
like a lot Jackie I'm feeling pretty
good about this it's this is not okay
why is it not okay she someone should
not nobody should be forced to look at
what I'm doing Oh Jackie I've never seen
you go through this many emotions before
I'm very stressed out he's horrifying
I've never seen such a monstrous
creation come out of my own hands okay
drew three versions of Snoopy you threw
three words Easy's is gonna be super
accurate does he have like those things
that dogs have little spots no no okay
no things though okay and his eyes are
always closed I think he's pretty
minimalist okay stop overthinking this
Jason finish your drawing it's done are
you done yeah I don't know what else to
do to it right how about we have a
positive attitude how about that hey
guys I'm done with my drawing I love
Garfield what a guy what a guy that
Garfield
he hates Mondays oh he loves lasagna
I drew guy let's calm Archie he's got
freckles and a big R on his shirt and
that's all I remember from Archie so I
feel great
yeah yeah like his five fingers you got
the the peanuts dancing is spot-on yeah
okay that's the thing I remember I was
like you had to do that little lady that
yeah let's dance it's not fair what do
you mean looks just like him yeah cuz I
grew up drawing Garfield Wow
you gave him some disturbingly human eye
you I just noticed his feet his feet are
frightening Jackie I said he had
human-like feet and you literally gave
him human feet this is like ridiculously
appealing he's got an arm freckles me
remember yeah yeah okay he's got like a
big expressive mouth he's got he does
Wow okay I think yours is way closer
than mine I mean with the collar he does
have a collar yeah he's got freckles yes
oh we did have whiskers but they're up
on his head they're like on the side of
his head why does yours look so much
Garfield Garfield is such a
weird-looking cat he is a weird-looking
cat it's because it's you know 40 years
of refining the character they just
becomes more and more abstract he also
had did you say he had heron yeah
I know I had like whiskers is what I was
thinking but he has eyebrows that I did
yes I guess he has eyebrows yeah he does
have thick eyebrows yeah yeah
got the thick eyebrows I was way off on
the hair his mouth thing was so weird
right that was the one thing that I
remember the most about him was his
mouth and how they constructed it like
Garfield he's my enemy now how can you
not like girlfr Garfield has made an
enemy today Wow yeah Garfield is the
most beloved cartoon cat in history
that's not true Hello Kitty would like
something to say
snoopy yeah he's been perfected by
Schultz over decades of comic drawing
there's some kind of beauty in that
simplicity you get like you just get him
down to his basic forms you know his
iconic shapes yeah
and he's he's unforgettable you know
except when you have to draw him from
memory
[Music]